[Musique]
cette capacité à faire de la musique
michel sauvage la savoure désormais
encore plus que d'habitude
il est rentré chez lui il ya une dizaine
de jours après avoir été hospitalisé
pour le coc u19 il sortait de croisière
en tant qu'artiste invité sur le costa
favolosa et avait repris le travail
quand le virus a frappé j'étais au
travail se sentent et j'avais l'estomac
j'ai commencé à tousser des ennemis
d'allah et est du coup je me suis dit
c'est pas moi je le faisais signe
jusqu'à un mot n'a pu me voir
et puis ma demander ce qui n'allait pas
les deux je ne sens pas du tout bien il
m'a demandé est ce que j'étais soit
bateau mais à l'époque on ne faisait que
prendre la température à la sortie du
bateau michel fait partie des premiers
hospitalisé c'est à ce moment qu'il
prend conscience de la situation
c'est surtout le soir la prise en charge
ça s'est bien passé
déjà j'ai d'autres chats propose que je
pense que c'est pas évident pour saison
ils ont beaucoup de boulot pour
m'équiper et il faut il faut pas qu'il y
ait des gens dans le court
il passe au monde c'est quand notre
salle est intéressant c'est que je
pensais de 0,2 et ça ça te touche âgé de
54 ans sans aucun facteur aggravant
michel sauvage sort de l'hôpital le 20
mars dernier
on lui demande de rester à domicile
pendant huit jours et la mairie informe
et puisqu'il est le frère du maire vient
prendre de ses nouvelles
mais s'il se remet sans dommages de
cette maladie il ne peut pas en dire
autant de la douzaine d'amis parfois
très proches qui étaient avec lui en
croisière quatre sont guéris mais s'ils
sont toujours hospitalisés et certains
en réanimation
alors il a un message à faire passer il
faut que les gens fassent très attention
et j'ai vu énormément d'imagés vidéo
comme elles étaient je me suis dit que
j'étais pour me gorny
on noue et se dénoue